rashad i um
i i've been to a lot of fights but you
had a fight coming up and i followed
your fights you were
you were something else been watching
your fight you i'm we're the same age i
think you and i are maybe your part i
don't know exactly how old you're 42.
i'm 43. so same era i'm watching you're
coming up i'm just watching how you're
fighting
uh my buddy len cooper who was one of
our vps in the company i took him to the
fight it's his birthday yesterday but
happy birthday len cooper uh took him to
go watch you and jackson fight which was
insane to go watch you fight but walk us
through the past man how you got into
everybody's got a different story how
they get into the ufc what's your story
coming up uh well i was in lansing
michigan and uh i was um working at this
bar
and uh i was just graduating from
college and i was you know doing a
little bit of bouncing work and a fight
broke out and um i was a ufc fan back in
the day and i used to watch it back in
1993 when it first came out so it went
through that dark area where not a lot
of people knew about it and knew what
was going on with it and the fight broke
out and the guy was like oh man he put
him in a rear naked choke now when he
said that it kind of like i was like oh
okay not many people know what that was
so then i started to inquire you know
okay you know how'd you know what that
was and then he said that he trains nhb
because it's called no holds bar at the
time
and i was like okay where you do that at
and he told me where he did it at
and um you know we went to the gym the
following monday and it was this beat
down run down like dilapidated building
and it had rats and stuff in it and uh
we go in there this building and i'm
thinking i'm about to get set up and
robbed i'm like oh man this don't seem
safe at all in michigan in michigan
atlanta michigan it was just like a very
seedy area and uh we go to the room
where the train and it's a little small
room like 12 by nine and these guys are
just beating the hell out of each other
they're just like taking turns you know
going against each other just like
full-on sparring just nothing i ever
seen before so uh i went and i tried it
that day and i was like hooked so i kept
on going there and kept training with
those guys and then after a while you
know we just got tired of beating the
hell out of each other it was like a
real life fight club like you know it
was like doctors lawyers and like
underground type underground type of
guys yeah that's that's what we'll do
for training but we were just beating
the hell out of each other so we wanted
some new meat and uh we started to uh we
linked up with dan severin and dan seven
was in coldwater michigan so we started
driving out to coldwater michigan and
training with those guys now at the time
dan severan was doing
his uh his fight promotion which was in
indiana angola indiana and on the indian
reservations because the ufc at the time
was only allowed to be in vegas and dan
was like i'm gonna have you know the
only show outside of uh of vegas you
know so we'll fight on these indian
reservations and uh dan dan severan was
inducted into ufc hall of fame
and then he said to me uh you know i
have an opportunity to have one of my
you know they'll look at one of my guys
uh but the thing about it is um you know
have you heard of the ultimate fighter
and i was like yeah i heard the ultimate
fight i watched the first season and
then he says okay uh well they're doing
a second season but it's heavyweights
though and he said you're way too small
you're like you know 195 pounds and i
was like i can be heavyweight so i just
started eating a lot of carbs and just
bulking up as big as i could get and um
you know i got on the ultimate fighter
show
and from there uh
i won the ultimate fighter show and then
that's how my ufc career started but it
was uh you know started in lansing
michigan now were you were you a fight
like if if we're in high school did you
have a reputation for a guy that don't
mess with rashad or did you have that
kind of reputation yeah i'll just do it
in high school yeah at what age did
people know like at what age you knew
you could fight oh man probably like in
um
probably like in fifth grade i was i was
fighting for you or that dude in fifth
grade that's like oh he's gonna roll up
on you fifth grade well i mean because i
went i went to like a majority white
school so
all those white boys well i was always
at target you know what i'm saying you
know they always say stuff so i mean i i
would fight on the way home from school
uh walking home from school my brother
would make me fight people he would make
you fight people yeah he'll tell me to
fight him in what ways that guy said
something to you gonna go fight him or
yeah i mean if like somebody like looked
at me a certain way he's like yo go
fight him and if i had his older brother
oh the brother yeah
and if i didn't fight that guy then he
he had beat me up so was he a fighter
was he a tough guy himself yeah he was a
tough guy yeah he sounds like he was
more like a promoter
all right go find that guy take his
lunch money yeah and you can beat that
guy we're gonna come here next week
is it because you were scared of your
older brother and didn't want him to
whoop your ass was it just like you had
that itch inside what was that
relationship with your brother well i
mean you know i was scared of my older
brother but at the same time him and i
will fight all the time you know and um
you know we just we just grew up how
many years older is he than you he's two
years older than this is like tikka and
david
so dylan yesterday for the first time
said something very weird to me
and you know he's taking classes right
now he's going to borrow three times a
week two times a week and he's his
middle son is just absolutely swim every
day and he's now doing soccer he's doing
all these other things like just one of
these guys that's very athletic like you
see him you're going to say sarah's
going to play something right the middle
eastern bow just like he just loves like
he loves fighting like there's something
about it that he likes he's eight years
old first time he's ever said something
like he says that one day i'm going to
be the greatest fighter in the world i
said what
he's never like he's never said i'm
going to be the greatest anything just
out of nowhere he just said daddy you
know what i i want to also learn how to
box i want to also learn how to do this
so by the way we got to keep this in
mind we don't watch videos like we don't
sit here and say let's watch this fight
video let's watch this youtube video
this guy's taking bara his coaches
inspired him and he says i want to be
the best fighter in the world one day so
it's i don't know if it starts there or
not obviously a lot of kids probably
have said this before but he has that
can i say one thing about dylan we're
making him sound like he's some
tough like these sweetest sweetest
nicest kids yeah so the fact that he
wants to be the nut it makes no sense
yeah because he's almost like you you're
such like a just a sweet nice guy at
least from what i can tell so far well
once paul comes to your different side
is going to show up but it's interesting
how do you balance like the sugar the
sweet side with just knocking mofos out
how does that duopoly work well i mean
it's uh you know
it's
i'd say whatever bothers me in life and
i just leave it for for the training you
know i learned at a at a young age to
kind of um you know learn how to uh
put my frustrations into sports and
things like that so now i just become
second nature to me so outside in real
life you know i'm just kind of calm and
just relax and i can take a lot of
and then
when it comes it's a switch it's a
switch yeah so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]